nous sommes au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à mes côtés
paul hermitage qui est le directeur du
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et philippe
pilato qui est le chef des opérations du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines mais il va y avoir du
changement c'est bien ça messieurs c'est
ça dans 72 heures 72 heures voilà on va
on va passer les codes nucléaires les
codes nucléaires avant passé de droite à
gauche et voilà je vais donner à
philippe les clés de la maison
alors pourquoi vous quittez le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
paul après si je me trompe pas six
années ici vous êtes arrivé en le 1er
septembre 2014 c'est ça ce sera
exactement six ans un petit peu plus
parce que j'ai j'ai quand même commencé
à apprendre le bébé en main à partir de
juin juillet 2014
pourquoi je pars parce que j'ai coché à
peu près toutes les cases qui était sur
sûrement job description sur sur la
fiche de mission qu'on m'avait donné à
l'époque et je suis un homme qui est
tellement de façons en mouvement qui a
besoin de mission et il est temps de
passer la main à quelqu'un d'autre pour
amener le groupe national dans une
nouvelle ère philippe pilate os que le
départ de paul r and it edge vous
surprend ou pas vous avez peut-être un
petit peu discuté avant me surprend
bah oui et non sur le côté on va dire
humains affectif j'aurais bien
évidemment voulu continuer l'aventuré
avec paul pascon on a travaillé en
étroite collaboration depuis maintenant
six ans on a fait beaucoup de choses
ensemble m'a appris beaucoup de choses
également et
une nouvelle vision et ce qu'on a réussi
à mettre en place et voilà par rapport à
ce que nous a dit à son arrivée après
maintenant comme il l'a dit paul c'est
un jeu c'est que c'est un homme j'ai
appris à le connaître et je sais que
c'est un homme de challenge et je sais
que voilà il a il fallait il fallait qui
rebondit sur autre chose et je pense que
c'est une bonne chance une belle
opportunité pour lui par rapport à par
rapport à son futur son futur
professionnel de votre futur
professionnel justement paul oui ça sera
quoi alors je reste dans le golfe je
reste en france je reste
pas loin paris on se débarrasse pas
aussi facilement que ça je vais
rejoindre un groupe français au niveau
de leurs opérations pour aider aussi
cette entreprise là en présence d'une
nouvelle ère également qui a envie de
moderniser que de changer parmi les
moments forts de votre carrière ici au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il y a eu
forcément pour les open de france mais
la ryder cup 2018 une première ici en
france forcément c'est votre plus beau
souvenir ici au golf national
alors non c'est parle c'est pas votre
plus beau souvenir non c'est pas le plus
beau souvenir parce que c'est
dès que je suis arrivé on m'a fixé
d'autres objectifs et m'ont plu
beau souvenir c'est ce qu'on a atteint
sur un plan humain c'est clair c'est la
ryder cup était positionné dans comment
dire dans tous les challenges qu'il y
avait évidemment c'était important mais
ça aurait été un désastre si on n'avait
pas eu une équipe à la hauteur et ça
aurait été encore plus désastreux si on
n'avait pas une prestation pour les
clients à la hauteur de ce qu'ils
imaginent d'un site de rise up blanc
c'est tout ça autour qui est le plus je
dire ouais le plus excitant pour nous la
ryder cup bien sûr on à y participer
de tous les jours
parce que multilingue on était impliqué
dans l'organisation même pendant
l'événement et c'est un rêve mais j'ai
pu visiter presque une dizaine d'autres
ryder cup dans ma vie en angleterre aux
etats unis un peu partout en tant que
fan et je l' ai vécu à l'intérieur un
peu comme ça aussi
donc c'est tout autour c'est les deux
années avant surtout l'accélération vers
l'événement et puis les deux années
avant sa de de travailler avec des
personnes qui avaient envie qu'ils
avaient vraiment envie de faire une
réussite de la rédac filippi lato vous
vous aurez également d'autres objectifs
il ya notamment les jo 2000 24 qui sont
organisées ici vous avez ouvrait
également cette ryder cup 2018 en france
forcément c'est un challenge excitant
pour vous bah oui jeux olympiques ça va
être formidable
c'est vrai que d'organiser cette épreuve
à quillan évident on va dire d'un
sportif et les preuves qu'on souhaitait
à laquelle on souhaite participer c'est
quand même formidable mais je le
placerais aussi également un peu comme
la ryder cup sur comment on a pu en
parler avec paul ryder cup c'est une
étape
voilà et notre notre travail c'est est
de préparer au mieux d'être le plus près
possible pour pour accueillir et faire
en sorte à ce que c'était que cette
étape soit bien vécue par les
collaborateurs soient bien vécu bien des
villans par le public et les jo je pense
qu'on va l'aborder exactement de la même
façon une étape dans la vie d'ailleurs
les championnats du monde amateurs
championnat d'europe jeux olympiques d
open de france sont tout un tas des
tables sur lesquelles il faut qu'on soit
à la hauteur et sur lesquels on doit
mobiliser les équipes oui est ce que
vous êtes un petit peu de différence sur
votre manière de penser
le golf national ou est ce que vous êtes
d'accord à peu près surtout philippe
elain une histoire qui est différente
de la mienne philippe est ici depuis 26
ans à chaque fois que 10 21 ans j'ai
peur de le blesser parce que ça fait
longtemps et puis 25 ans et puis en plus
25 ans je ne suis pas donc depuis 26 ans
philippe est là felipe est un est un
comment dire extrêmement fidèle loyal à
la fédération française de golf
moi aussi pendant la période dans
laquelle j'étais ici c'est pas ça que je
veux dire mais on n'a pas la même
histoire moi je suis arrivé à un moment
où il y avait un besoin et il y avait
une étape à franchir il y avait besoin
peut-être d'amener une ressource
extérieure aujourd'hui c'est pas que ça
roule parce qu'il y aura toujours
quelque chose qui arrive au golf
national toujours il ya plein tous les
jours il ya quelque chose qui arrive
aujourd'hui à l'équipe de france qui
s'entraîne
c'est sans fin mais on est arrivé à un
1 comment dire un organisation qui est
pas mal optimisé avec de bonnes équipes
de bonnes personnes sur lequel philippe
peut compter c'est à dire qu'on a créé
cette équipe ensemble c'est un peu plus
c'est pas facile ce ne sera jamais
facile mais c'est un peu plus stable
dernière question qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter filippi la tour vous
allez bientôt commencer qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter de faire aussi bien
paul voilà de faire aussi milieu et
faire mieux voilà mon objectif c'est de
faire mieux c'est de le battre est donc
donc donc voilà non mais c'est ça c'est
de réussir toujours bienvenu au golf
national pour une partie l'avant et on
va lui faire une carte de membre membre
honoraire à vie
non oui c'est de baisser de faire c'est
de faire voilà aussi bien voire mieux
que ce qu'on a fait ces six dernières
années de porter le golf national là où
il doit être
c'est au sommet au sommet de la pyramide
du golf en france et voilà est de faire
en sorte à ce que tous les événements
qui seront les prochains des nôtres on
les mène les mène à bien palermitaine
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter à
vous aussi
on bat la même chose que je vous
souhaite beaucoup beaucoup de succès et
d'être heureux et ça ne manquera pas
merci à tous les deux merci pour cette
interview et on vous souhaite beaucoup
de courage et bonne chance pour vos
nouvelles fonctions merci le couvrir